einen schönen guten tag aus hagen und
herzlich willkommen zu dieser online
vorlesung in der ich ihnen gerne ein
bisschen ja über die methoden
geschichtliche entwicklungen der
qualitativen sozialforschung erzählen
möchte die er mittlerweile fest
etabliert ist im werkzeugkasten der uns
als forschende so zur verfügung steht
und die ich würde denken spätestens seit
den 1980 er jahren auch anerkannt ist
als quantitativen ansätzen gegenüber
gleichwertige forschungs logik so weit
die lage heute die geschichte
qualitative sozialforschung die reicht
natürlich deutlich weiter zurück nämlich
bis in die mitte des achtzehnten
jahrhunderts da denke zum beispiel an
die göttinger kamera listen die
seinerzeit ja doch sehr explizite kritik
daran geübt hatten die soziale welt
alleine durch eine statistische brille
zu betrachten ihre neue sichtweise
konnten sie zunächst aber nicht
durchsetzen was vermutlich auch daran
lag dass es ihrer perspektive auf
forschung an einem methodologischen an
einem sozial theoretische fundament
mangelte
das wurde dann erst im laufe der zeit
nachgeholt
zum beispiel ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts denke ich an den
philosophen wilhelm dilthey und die
geisteswissenschaftliche hermeneutik ich
denke aber auch an max weber ja der ja
so an der wende vom 19
zwanzigste jahrhundert seiner
verstehenden soziologie ein dezidiertes
handlungs theoretisches fundament
gegeben hat und ich denke an karl
mannheim der zu beginn des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts die dokumentarische methode
entwickelt hat den wirklichen beginn der
modernen qualitativen sozialforschung
den würde ich dann allerdings so in den
1920 30er jahren vororten mit den
arbeiten der chicago school hat es waren
seinerzeit ja sehr im puristischen sehr
gegenstands bezogene sehr spezifische
feldstudien und in dieser zeit 1900 20er
30er jahre
fällt ja auch der erste meilenstein den
ich heute zusammen mit ihnen anschauen
möchte nämlich die studie die
arbeitslosen von marienthal
das wäre also die idee der heutigen
online vorlesungen dass ich ihn
wesentliche entwicklungsschritte eben
wesentliche meilensteine der entwicklung
qualitative sozialforschung anhand
dreier klassische studien vorstellen
in deren rahmen jeweils eine spezifische
methode oder methodisches vorgehen
entwickelt worden ist
ich glaube dass das einerseits einen
vorteil hat nämlich dass man an der
erstmaligen verwendung einer methode in
besonders prägnante weise ihre grundidee
oder ihre basalen methodischen
prinzipien erkennen kann
es hat das muss man dazu sagen
vielleicht allerdings auch einen
nachteil nämlich dass natürlich alle
drei methoden über die ich heute
sprechen möchte seit ihrer ersten
verwendung in diesen meilenstein studien
teils entscheidend weiterentwickelt
worden sind drei studien also die erste
die arbeitslosen von marienthal und
diese drei studien möchte ich ihnen
jeweils in mehreren schritten vorstellen
ich würde zunächst damit beginnen ihnen
die autorinnen und autoren der
jeweiligen studie vorzustellen ja das
halte ich durchaus für wichtig dass man
mit bedenkt wie man eine bestimmte
methode eigentlich zu verdanken hat oder
etwas weniger flapsig formuliert ja so
dass man auch die kontexte sowohl die
historischen als auch die biografischen
kontext mit bedenkt wenn man eine studie
betrachtet würde ihnen dann das
erkenntnisinteresse der jeweiligen
studie und die damit zusammenhängenden
forschungsfragen erläutern und mich dann
im weiteren vor allem auf zwei dinge
konzentriert nämlich einerseits
natürlich auf die methoden die in der
jeweiligen studie entwickelt worden sind
im falle von marienthal haben wir es
hier mit etwas zu tun dass die autorin
selbst als sozia graffy bezeichnen
und wenn man so will auf neue
soziologisch formuliert haben wir es zu
tun mit einem mixed messedesign in dem
quantitative und qualitative methoden
miteinander kombiniert werden
ich würde ihnen dann gerne auch jeweils
kurz die untersuchungsergebnisse der
jeweiligen studien skizzieren das kann
heute natürlich nur sehr
holzschnittartig ja und sehr
schlaglichtartig geschehen aber
gleichwohl ist es ja wichtig mal zu
sehen was man eigentlich mit einer
bestimmten methode herausfinden kann und
der andere punkt auf denen ich bei allen
drei studien gerne näher eingehen möchte
das sind die gütekriterien qualitative
sozialforschung also bestimmte kriterien
anhand dessen anhand derer man die
qualität einer studie beurteilen kann
die kenntnis dieser gütekriterien halte
ich für wichtig also einerseits dann
wenn man die studien anderer
forscherinnen und forscher ließen und
kritisch reflektieren möchte
beispielsweise welchen einfluss ein
spezifisches untersuchungs design auf
die dann am ende stehen
untersuchungsergebnisse hatte und
andererseits sind diese gütekriterien
natürlich auch immer dann wichtig wenn
man selbst forscht beispielsweise eine
qualifikations arbeit schreibt ja weil
sie ihnen diese gütekriterien einem dann
anhaltspunkte an die hand geben was es
in forschungs praktischer hinsicht zu
beachten gilt
die gütekriterien über die ich im falle
von marina ansprechen möchte dass es
einerseits die gegenstands
angemessenheit sehr zentrales
gütekriterien auch glaube ich ein großes
spezifikum qualitative forschungsansätze
und das andere ist der subjektive
einfluss der forschenden auf ihrem
untersuchungsgegenstand ja der er immer
wenn man so will ein problem
sozialwissenschaftlicher forschung ist
die zweite studie stammt aus den usa
trägt den titel werners auf dein von
vanek laser und an dem strauß eine
studie in der die beiden sich mit
sterbenden patienten in
amerikanischen krankenhäusern
beschäftigt haben inhaltlich und deren
kontext sie die grounded theory
methodologie entwickelt haben
das ist ja eine heute sehr prominente
methode ja die häufig verwendet wird in
qualitativen studien
eigentlich ist sie gar nicht so sehr
eine konkrete methode sondern eher eine
art methodologie also ein sammelbecken
für ganz unterschiedliche methodische
vorgehensweisen da gibt es einige die
man so unter diesem stichwort brandet
riri subsumieren kann zwei davon möchte
ich heute raus greifen nämlich einmal
die idee des theoretischen samplings und
andererseits das kodieren und die
gütekriterien die man glaube ich gut
anhand von werners offen diskutieren
kann dass es einerseits die empirische
verankerung theoretischer modelle und
andererseits die limitation also die
frage inwieweit kann ich eigentlich die
untersuchungsergebnisse die ich anhand
eines bestimmten spezifischen
untersuchungsgegenstandes ja
herausarbeiten konnte inwiefern kann ich
die zu abstrakten modellen
generalisieren
und der dritte meilenstein die dritte
klassische studie über dich sprechen
möchte die trägt die täter psychologie
der krisenbewältigung der sg studie aus
deutschland an der philipp meiring
damals noch doktorand als doktorand
beteiligt war und in deren kontext die
qualitative inhaltsanalyse entwickelt
worden ist auch dass eine sehr
prominente methode die heute sehr häufig
angewandt wird
auch die sehr facettenreich und ich
denke ich kann sie nicht in gänze und in
allen ihren einzelheiten heute
darstellen aber auf zwei dinge möchte
ich doch eingehen die ich für wesentlich
halte wenn es oben qualitative
inhaltsanalyse geht nämlich das ist
einerseits ihre fähigkeit umfangreiches
datenmaterial mit dem es ja häufig bei
qualitative vor
zu tun hat mir also umfangreiches
datenmaterial zu reduzieren um es
überhaupt handhabbar zu machen ja um es
einer analyse und interpretation
zugänglich machen zu können und
andererseits die fähigkeit der
inhaltsanalyse
dieses umfangreiche datenmaterial zu
strukturieren
die beiden gütekriterien die ich anhand
der inhaltsanalyse diskutieren möchte
ist der einerseits dass man sich sicher
immer darum bemühen sollte den
forschungs erhebungs und auswertungs
prozess transparent zu machen wie ihn
wie man so sagt inters objektiv
nachvollziehbar zu machen und
andererseits möchte ich die frage der
offenheit diskutieren ja der offenheit
von forschenden gegenüber neuen und
vielleicht auch überraschenden
erkenntnissen im feld denn da wird der
inhaltsanalyse ja häufig vorgeworfen sie
sei aufgrund ihrer anlage eben nicht
hinreichend offen für unerwartete
ergebnisse dazu später mehr
ganz am ende würde ich diese
gütekriterien dann noch einmal
zusammenfassen und abschließend
argumentieren warum ich genau diese drei
studien heizzentrale meilenstein der
modernen qualitativen sozialforschung
betrachte beginnen wollen wir aber mit
diesen 34 paul lazarsfeld maria roeder
und hans zeisel den autorin der studie
die arbeitslosen von marienthal
alle drei wurden anfang des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts in wien geboren habe dort
studiert unterschiedliche fächer im fall
von lars feld war es die mathematik bei
oder was pädagogik und psychologie
reiserecht und staatswissenschaften alle
drei haben sich später dann getroffen
auch an der universität in wien an der
wirtschaftspsychologin forschungsstelle
die last seiner zeit geleitet hat und
die auch die institution war an der die
studie die arbeitslosen von marienthal
angesiedelt waren
und alle drei so viel zum relevanten
biografischen kontext jahre waren
jüdischen glaubens
was in den 1930 er jahren dazu führte
dass alle drei aus österreich emigrieren
mussten das feld hat das schon sehr früh
anfang der dreißiger jahre getan
aufgrund guter kontakte zur rockefeller
stiftung bei oder und reise ist die
migration deutlich später erfolg bei ihr
oder auch nicht ohne zwang sie war
nämlich politisch aktiv bei den so hieß
es damals revolutionären sozialisten
wurde deshalb auch kurzfristig
inhaftiert auf internationale
intervention aber wieder freigelassen
unter der auflage dass die österreich
verlässt genauso wie zeisel ist sie dann
nach england und in die usa gegangen wo
sie weiter geforscht und gelehrt hat das
feld und ja übrigens auch das noch zum
biografischen kontext waren
zwischenzeitlich miteinander verheiratet
und haben eine gemeinsame tochter
ja worum geht es in dieser wirklich
klassischen studie der qualitativen
sozialforschung es geht wie der name
schon sagt um marienthal dann bis zu tun
mit einem kleinen industrie dorf in der
nähe wiens in dem zwischen so zum
jahreswechsel 1929 1930 auf einen schlag
annähernd der komplette ort arbeitslos
wurde es gab nämlich in marienthal eine
fabrik aus der textilindustrie die wurde
infolge der weltwirtschaftskrise
geschlossen so dass die menschen
annähernd das gesamte dorf ja also drei
viertel der knapp 500 marienthaler
familien ja von einem tag auf den
anderen von arbeitslosigkeit betroffen
waren nur rund ein fünftel der
bevölkerung marienthal verfügte nach der
werksschließung noch über ein
regelmäßiges einkommen das aber ja da
alle marienthaler ihre kaufkraft
verloren hatten
dann teilweise auch deutlich unter dem
sozialhilfeniveau lag ja wir haben sie
in marienthal zu beginn des jahres 1930
also mit einer sehr besonderen
situationen zu tun
die tatsächlich sozialwissenschaftlich
sehr interessant ist weil wir es mit so
einer art labor situation zu tun haben
ja ein kompletter ort wird plötzlich
arbeitslos herbst kann man sich heute
eigentlich kaum noch vorstellen also
weil die welt heute organisiert ist wir
haben es weniger mit diesen dörflichen
strukturen so tun wie seinerzeit in
marienthal wir leben heute in einer
globalisierten welt in einer
pluralisierten diversifizierten
arbeitswelt er aber damals war sie
ebenso das annähernd der gesamte ort
abhängig war von dieser einen fabrik die
dann geschlossen wurde
diese laborsituation hat lars feld
geholt und sei sehr interessiert und das
ziel ihre studie das beschreiben sie
selbst folgendermaßen es ging ihnen
darum mit den mitteln moderner
erhebungsmethoden ein bild von der
psychologischen situation eines
arbeitslosen ortes zu geben
es waren uns schreiben sie von anfang an
zwei aufgaben wichtig die inhaltliche
nämlich zum problem der arbeitslosigkeit
material beizutragen
war ja seinerzeit ein neues phänomen die
massenarbeitslosigkeit ja und die zweite
aufgabe die methodische zu versuchen
einen sozialpsychologischen tatbestand
umfassend objektiv darzustellen
dieses anliegen war etwas neues denn in
den 1920 er jahren gab es im prinzip
zwei quellen ja sozialwissenschaftlicher
erkenntnis dass eine das waren
statistiken und da spreche ich gar nicht
so sehr von statistiken die aus
akademischen zusammenhängen standen also
nicht so sehr von quantitativer
sozialforschung sondern ich denke eher
an statistiken aus dem administrativen
politischen bereich also so etwas wie
arbeitslosenstatistiken die gab es
einerseits und andererseits gab es ein
genre das sich sozialreportagen nannte
ja das war aber auch kein genuin
wissenschaftliches chance sondern es war
eher ein journalistisches jahr das auch
dadurch sehr subjektiv gefärbt war durch
die sichtweise ja durch das reportieren
eines journalisten oder einer
journalistin die diese beiden quellen
gab es ja auch dazwischen klaffte so
eine art lücke die die autorin der
marien teilstudie zu schließen
versuchten und diesen versuch ja den
nennen sie selbst soziogramm oder wie es
im untertitel des büchleins genauer
heißt ein soziogramm fischen versuch
recht zurückhaltend formuliert und sie
schreiben zwischen den nackten ziffern
der offiziellen statistik und den allen
zufällen ausgesetzten eindrücken der
sozialen reportage klafft eine lücke
die auszufüllen sind unseres versuches
ist was uns vorschwebt
das war eine methode der darstellung die
die verwendung exakten zahlen materials
mit dem sich ein leben in die situation
verband und dieser letzte satz der gibt
ja schon einen hinweis darauf dass in
erstaunlich selbstverständliche art und
weise also in dieser mariental studie
quantitative mit qualitativen daten
triathleten wie man heute sagen würde ja
es wurde also auch das erneuerer begriff
ein mixed messe design gewählt das macht
lars feld in seinem vorwort der studie
auch sehr deutlich als er schreibt da es
gibt so viel zu tun dass man nicht seine
zeit mit methodenstreit vergeuden sollte
eine integrale soziologie wird mit allen
empirischen und analytischen mitteln an
konkrete probleme herangehen und dadurch
eine realistische synthese finden das
finde ich ein wirklich erstaunlichen
satz für den beginn der 1930 er jahre
weil er auch zeigt dass diese jahre dass
diese grabenkämpfe zwischen quantitative
und qualitative forschung die ich
durchaus noch kennen gelernt habe als
ich angefangen habe zu studieren ja dass
diese grabenkämpfe eigentlich erst
später ausgehoben wurden wenn man hier
am beginn moderner qualitativ
sozialforschung beides noch gleichwertig
miteinander in verbindung gebracht hat
das kleine büchlein hier die studie dass
sie neben mir sehen
das musste übrigens in der ersten
auflage 1933 ohne die nennung die
namensnennungen der autorin
veröffentlicht werden ja dort durfte
seinerzeit nur als herausgeben die
institutionen eben diese workshops
psychologische forschungsstelle stehen
und auch das reichte offenbar nicht in
den nationalsozialisten haben dann
alsbald diese erste auflage verboten und
alle bereits gedruckten exemplare
vernichtet mittlerweile aber liegt das
büchlein ende ich glaube schon 23
auflage vor und ich finde es bis heute
ein sehr plastisches sehr lesenswertes
kleines bändchen
wenn wir mal einen blick reinwerfen
zunächst auf das untersuchungs design
dann sehen wir ein ja ein wirklich
interessantes weil sehr breites spektrum
verwendeter erhebungsmethoden wir sehen
also auch ein sehr kreatives ja ein sehr
pragmatischer ein sehr originelles
forschungsdesign ganz unterschiedliche
daten sorten werden in der studie
berücksichtigt also auf quantitativer
seite beispielsweise eben besagte
statistiken so was für
bevölkerungsstatistik wahlstatistik
cetera pp
es wurden aber auch selbst quantitative
daten erhoben zb hat man haushalte
besucht inventarlisten geführt also
geschaut was besitzen die arbeitslosen
marienthal rinn eigentlich noch man hat
zeit verwendung bögen von den
arbeitslosen ausfüllen lassen das
schauen wir uns auch gleich ein beispiel
an
man hat dokumente analysiert so würde
man das heute nennen also zum beispiel
die die ausleih bücher der bibliothek
oder die die vereinsregister und man hat
standardisierte beobachtungen
durchgeführt auch
da schauen wir gleich noch mal ein
bisschen genauer ein weil ich das auch
einen von den wirklich originellen
forschungsansätzen innerhalb der studie
findet nämlich man hat die
gehgeschwindigkeit der marienthaler auf
der dorfstraße gemessen und er so im
qualitativen bereich hat mann tagebücher
analysiert man hat die schülerinnen und
schüler aufsätze schreiben lassen über
ihr leben und ihre wünsche das hat man
auch mit einem preisausschreiben
verbunden
und dann hat man viele veranstaltungen
organisiert bei denen dann beobachtungen
durchgeführt worden also beispielsweise
haben die forscherinnen in wien
kleiderspenden eingesammelt die sie dann
in marienthal verteilt haben ja sie
haben ärztinnen und ärzte eingeladen
sprechstunden in mariental durchzuführen
sie haben bestimmte kurse zur
erziehungsberatung zum spiel zeichnen et
cetera pp organisiert und schließlich
haben sie interviews geführt
ja und zwar einerseits interviews die
ich heute wohl experteninterviews nennen
würde also interviews zum beispiel mit
dem örtlichen lehrer mit dem fahrer mit
dem bürgermeister et cetera pp und sie
haben ausführliche biografische
interviews geführt mit den arbeitslosen
marienthaler ja und da rausgekommen sind
ist eine interview fragen die ich heute
vermutlich narratives interview nennt
wird wenn ich das so alles in gänze
anschaue dann habe ich eben gesagt also
die autorin selbst denn das sozio graffy
heute würde man vermutlich sagen das ist
ein ethnographische untersuchungs design
also reines in dem neben spezifischen
originellen methoden vor allen dingen
beobachtungen durchgeführt werden teils
ad rock kombiniert mit interviews
und wenn man jetzt mal in die daten
hereinschauen die durch diese methoden
erhoben worden sind dann spricht lars
feld von drei überraschenden
beobachtungen die ihm besonders
aufgefallen sind im kontext der studie
nämlich einerseits dass die arbeitslosen
von marienthal obwohl sie durch ihre
arbeitslosigkeit ja nun mehr zeit hatten
dass sie trotzdem weniger aktiv waren ja
also sie haben zum beispiel seltene die
bibliothek besucht und sich dort bücher
ausgeliehen obwohl sie so könnte man
sagen nun ja mehr zeit zum lesen gehabt
hätten ja sie waren auch weniger aktiv
im verein im turn- und gesangsverein das
hat beispielsweise um die
werksschließung herum
die zahl der mitglieder um die hälfte ja
und obwohl die arbeitslosen von morrien
teil natürlich unter ihrer schlechten
ökonomischen situation gelitten haben ja
waren sie weniger politisch engagiert
hat das feld beobachtet das macht er zum
beispiel daran fest dass weniger
menschen die arbeiter zeitung abonniert
haben ja um 60 prozent ist die quote da
zwischen 1927 und 1930 eingebrochen auch
die zahl der mitglieder der
sozialdemokratischen partei ist
zurückgegangen und drittens hat lars
feld auch für ihn überraschend
beobachtet ja dass die arbeitslosen
selbst weniger versuche unternommen
haben in anderen orten neue arbeit zu
finden als es diejenigen getan haben die
auch im mariental eigentlich noch arbeit
gehabt hätten und ein schlaglicht was
wir vielleicht mal werfen könnten wo man
glaube ich noch mal so dieses regulative
forschungsdesign ja diesen blick auf
einen aspekt aus mehreren richtungen gut
sehen kann
das sind die essgewohnheiten der
marienthaler ja also die wurden
einerseits standardisiert erfasst in
form
statistische kennzahlen also mann hatte
zum beispiel festgestellt dass am tag
vor der auszahlung der
arbeitslosenunterstützung ja weniger als
50 prozent der schulkinder ein
ausreichendes frühstück mit in die
schule bekommen haben und am tag nach
der auszahlung der
arbeitslosenunterstützung waren es dann
wieder 95 prozent der kinder die
essgewohnheiten wurden aber auch in den
interviews thematisiert also da habe ich
ihnen mal ein ja ein vielleicht sehr
drastisches sehr beeindruckendes zitat
mitgebracht aus dem interview mit einem
arbeitslosen marienthaler der erzählt
immer wieder verschwinden katzen die
katze von herrn h ist erst vor wenigen
tagen verschwunden katzenfleisch ist
sehr gut
auch hunde werden gegessen erst vor
wenigen tagen bekam ein mann von einem
bauern einen hund geschenkt unter der
bedingung dass er hin schmerzlos
erschlägt
und schließlich wurden in puncto
essgewohnheiten auch speise und
budgetpläne zusammengestellt in dem
besuchten haushalten ein punkt wo ich
eben schon mal darauf hingewiesen hatte
den ich sehr kreativ finder als
forschungsmethode dass es die messung
der geschwindigkeit ja es gab in
marienthal eine kleine dorfstraße ja
also die war vielleicht 100 meter langen
ja nicht länger und da hat man also
einerseits geschaut mit stoppuhr wie
schnell die menschen sich auf dieser
straße bewegen und man hat gezählt wie
oft sie auf diesen 100 metern stehen
bleiben ja und das ist zum beispiel hier
in dieser tabelle aufgelistet ja und da
sieht man dass nun 39 männer ja auf
dieser kleinen dorfstraße dreimal oder
sogar noch öfter stehen geblieben sind
als sie entlang gegangen sind ja und nur
sechs männer sind die
straße zügig gegangen ohne stehen zu
bleiben und die lage sieht bei frauen
ein interessanter weise ganz anders aus
also hier gibt es nur wenige die oft
stehen bleiben und der große teil bleibt
kein mann oder nur einmal stehen und
daraus folgern die autorin dass die
lebenswerte arbeitslosigkeit also sich
für frauen anders darstellt als für
männer
ja weil frauen noch stärker in dieser
zeit eingebunden sind in die
familienpflichten was ihnen auch einen
gewissen lebenssinn gibt ja und eine
aufgabe die sie zu erfüllen haben so
dass sie weniger stark abgleiten ja in
so einen selbst als sinnlos
wahrgenommenes leben wie die männlichen
arbeitslosen überhaupt sind diese gender
aspekte nicht uninteressant in der
marien studie weil es immer wieder um
geschlechtsspezifische unterschiede geht
was durchaus eine neue perspektive ist
in den 1920 er 1930 er jahren und auch
maria roters rolle darf man dabei
sicherlich nicht unterschätzen so die
diese perspektive mit eingebracht hat
und die überhaupt ja sehr zentral an der
studie beteiligt war
in den 1920 30er jahren als weibliche
forscherin ja als auch das eine
besonderheit man munkelt dass sie es
eigentlich war die diese studie am ende
wirklich auch geschrieben hat ein
beispiel aus den daten möchte ich ihnen
noch kurz zeigen nämlich diese besagten
zeit erfassungsbögen ja also man hat den
arbeitslosen tabellen an die hand
gegeben in der sie für jede stunde des
tages eintragen sollten was sie in
dieser stunde getan haben das sollten
sie wohl gemerkt erschöpfend machen also
sollten alles aufschreiben was sie getan
haben und wenn man diese zeit
erfassungsbögen so liest dann
die auch sehr beeindruckend also zum
beispiel dieser arbeitslose hier
schreibt in der 6 uhr stunde stehe ich
auf 7 uhr wirklich die buchen da sie in
die schule müssen acht uhr wenn sie fort
sind gehe ich zum stoppen bringen holz
und wasser heraus 9 uhr wenn ich den
aufgang fragt mich meine frau was sie
kochen soll in dieser frage zu entgehen
gehe ich in die auf 10 uhr einstweilen
wird es mittag 11 uhr nichts 12 uhr
nichts 1 uhr wird gegessen da die kinder
aus der schule kommen nach dem essen die
zeitung durchgesehen bin
hinuntergegangen zum kaufmann gegangen
und so weiter und so fort
also ein wirklich recht inaktiver tag
der arbeitslosigkeit und dieses zitat
passieren der 10 uhr stunde sehen
übrigens einstweilen wird es mittag das
ist der titel eines films geworden den
karen brand war ende der 80er jahre
gedreht hat nicht nur über marienthal
sondern auch über diese studie
ja das macht diesen film finde ich sehr
interessant also weil ich nur wenige
beispiele davon für filmen kenne die
sich nicht nur mit einem
forschungsgegenstand beschäftigen
sondern auch mit dem forschungsalltag
der forschenden ja also wir sehen hier
richtig oder unze wie sie in mariental
die daten erheben und in welche
schwierigen situationen ja auch in
welche konflikte sie dabei geraten also
durchaus ein sehenswerter film 12 wird
es mittag wenn wir einen kurzen blick
werfen auf die untersuchungsergebnisse
ja die jetzt aus der zusammenschau all
dieser und noch deutlich mehr daten
entstanden sind dann haben wir es im
fall von mariental zu tun mit einer
typologie haben es ja eine sehr häufige
form des ergebnisses eine sehr häufige
form des theoretischen
dells das aus einer qualitativen studie
entsteht und im fall von marienthal
haben die forschenden also vier haltungs
gruppen von arbeitslosen wie sie das
nennen voneinander abgegrenzt nämlich
einerseits die resignierten die
beschreiben sie mit folgenden worten das
gleichmütig erwartungs lose dahin leben
die einstellung man kann ja doch nichts
gegen die arbeitslosigkeit machen dabei
eine relativ ruhige stimmung sogar immer
wieder auftauchende heitere augenblicks
freude verbunden mit dem verzicht auf
eine zukunft die nicht einmal mehr in
der fantasie als plan eine rolle spielt
das zweite gruppe die so genannten
ungebrochenen jahr ihre haushaltsführung
ist genau so geordnet wie die der
resignierten aber ihre bedürfnisse sind
weniger reduziert ihr horizont ist
weiter ihre energie ist größer die
verzweifelten diese menschen sind völlig
verzweifelt und nach dieser
grundstimmung erhielt die verhaltens
gruppe ihren namen wie die ungebrochenen
und resignierten halten auch sie in
ihrem haushalt noch ordnung pflegen auch
sie ihre kinder und schließlich die
apathische mit apathischer in talence
dass man den dingen ihren lauf
ohne den versuch zu machen etwas vor dem
verfall zu retten das hauptkriterium für
diese haltung ist das energie lose
tatenlose zu sehen wohnung und kindes
und unsauber und ungepflegt die stimmung
ist nicht verzweifelt sondern student
wenn ich gesagt habe also eine typologie
an sich ist eine häufige der ergebnis
form qualitative studien so fallen zwei
besonderheiten hierauf nämlich
einerseits das quantifiziert wird also
dass man angibt wie groß eine gruppe
prozentual ist das geschieht eher selten
muss man vielleicht auch kritisch und
der fragen bei den für qualitative
forschung ja typischerweise eher kleinen
das andere ist dass wir es hier genau
genommen ja nicht nur mit einem
nebeneinander verschiedener haltungs
gruppen zu tun haben sondern dass diese
typologie auch einen prozess beschreibt
ein prozess der folgen von
arbeitslosigkeit ja nämlich von den
ungebrochenen über die resignierten über
die verzweifelten bis hin zu den
apathischen das ist also wenn sie mich
fragen das zentrale ergebnis der studie
neben vielen weiteren beobachtungen und
und weiteren ergebnissen
wenn man sich jetzt mal die frage
gestellt was ist mit den gütekriterien
bei dem bei der marienthal studie
dann fällt mir als erstes die
gegenstands angemessenheit auf das ist
vielleicht ein zentrales merkmal
qualitative forschung dass sie versucht
ihren ihr forschungsdesign an ihren
gegenstand anzupassen
das ist ja ein großer unterschied zu
quantitative forschung ja jörg strübing
spricht deshalb von einer umkehr des
verhältnisses von forschungsgegenstand
forschungsmethode denn wenn sie schon
einmal einen standardisierten fragebogen
in einer quantitativen studie ausgefüllt
haben dann wissen sie ja also da sind
die fragebogen fragen die sind einfach
so formuliert wie sie sind ja und sie
haben auch nur die möglichkeit die
antwort felder die es da gibt
anzukreuzen
ja das heißt natürlich aus gutem grund
ich werde das nicht im grundsatz
kritisieren ist es so dass in
quantitativer forschung natürlich man
versucht möglichst gelungen ja den
forschungsgegenstand einzupassen in
seinen untersuchungen design und da geht
man in qualitativer forschung eben den
umgekehrten weg so dass man sich darum
bemüht
ja seine methodik derart anzupassen dass
sie dem untersuchungsgegenstand
angemessen ist also dass sie ihnen
erfassen kann und dass sie dazu in der
lage ist die forschungsfrage auch
wirklich zu beantworten
sie müssen also wenn sie qualitativ
forschen wollen nicht so sehr ein stures
analyse schema abarbeiten sondern sie
müssen immer wieder schauen dass ihr
einzelnen methoden oder einzelne punkte
ihres methodischen dieser 1 anpassen und
so verfeinern dass das design eben in
der lage ist ihre forschungs frage zu
beantworten und dabei den gegenstand
nicht zu verfälschen
apropos beeinflussung des gegenstands
ein anderes kriterium was man glaube ich
ein bisschen kritisch sehen muss bei der
marienthaler studie
das ist die reflektierte subjektivität
er ist es ja eine besonderheit der
empirischen sozialforschung dass wir
nicht wie naturwissenschaftler es tun
experimente durchführen können in denen
wir alle bedingungen kontrollieren
können und in denen wir selbst nahezu
ausschließen können dass wir durch
unsere forschung selbst einfluss nehmen
ja auf den auf das experiment das ist
bei uns nicht so ja sondern wir sind
natürlich mittendrin wenn wir eine
teilnehmende beobachtung durchführen
also wenn wir eine soziale gruppe
besuchen und die interaktionen dort
beobachten oder wenn wir jemanden
interviewen dann nehmen wir natürlich
per se einfluss auf unseren
untersuchungsgegenstand da kommt man
auch nicht drum denn auch als forschen
ja sind wir menschen und teil der
sozialen welt die wir forschen aber es
gilt während des gesamten qualitativen
forschungsprozesses natürlich dass man
sich immer fragen muss ja wie groß das
mein einfluss auf die
untersuchungsergebnisse also ist es so
dass die gruppe sich anders verhält nur
weil ich sie beobachte ja
ist es so dass meine interviewpartner
denn in bestimmter weise meine fragen
beantwortet einfach weil ich da bin oder
weil ich die frage in einer bestimmten
art und weise stelle ja man sollte sich
also permanent selbst beobachten als
qualitative forscherin oder qualitative
forschung
ja man muss sehen ob man zu viel distanz
zum untersuchungsgegenstand hat ihn
dadurch gar nicht verstehen kann oder ob
man zu nah der handels boeing native
also ob man so sehr involviert ist in
das forschungsfeld dass man keine
analytische distanz mehr fahren kann
das ist sicherlich ein problem der
marienthal studie also bei da dieses
soziale engagement mit reinspielt diese
kleidersammlung ja diese veranstaltung
von schnitt zeichen kursen et cetera pp
im fall von marienthal hat man das
übrigens versucht zu lösen indem die
forschen da zwischenzeitlich immer
wieder nach wien gefahren sind und
supervisionen durchgeführt haben
man muss sich auch während des
forschungsprozesses beständig fragen ja
ob man eigentlich die persönlichen
voraussetzungen erfüllt um in einem
bestimmten feld zu forschen und das ist
eine problematik die man sehr schön in
diesem besagten film sehen kann
einstweilen wird es mittag denn man muss
doch sagen dass für die forscherinnen ja
diese lebenswelt von mariental eine
völlig fremde welt war ja wo man sich
auch fragen musste also können diese
studierten menschen aus wie ja
eigentlich die lebenswelt der
arbeitslosen von marienthal wirklich
verstehen ja sowas geht es zu
reflektieren also spätestens dann wenn
konflikte auftreten dass es in
marienthal durchaus passiert ja und ein
dritter wichtiger punkt der
reflektierten subjektivität ja oder
worum es eigentlich ja geht es immer
dann wenn ich qualitativ forscher auch
wenn ich quantitativ forscher denke ich
brauche ich vertrauen beim 1
man sagt immer so forschungsgegenstand
also bei den menschen die ich beobachte
oder die interviewer brauche ich
vertrauen damit sie sich mehr öffnen und
in interviews berichten und bei
beobachtungen eben so agieren wie sie
auch ohne beobachtung agieren würden
das wiederum haben die in marienthal
erforschenden meiner einschätzung nach
gut gelöst durch das soziale engagement
denn eben diese kleiderspenden
spendenaktionen diese ärzte
sprechstunden et cetera pp
die haben großes vertrauen bei den
marienthaler geschaffen
ja und damit zum zweiten meilenstein der
qualitativen sozialforschung und zu
diesen beiden ehrbar nick laser und an
seinem strauß beide er aus den usa haben
ende
san francisco zusammen gelehrt und
geforscht und zwar in einer studie
die motiviert wurde durch ein
persönliches erkenntnisinteresse ja das
ist ja auch sehr häufig so dass man
irgendwie aus persönlichen gründen auf
einen forschungsgegenstand stößt der 1
interessiert und wo man dann ein
bisschen genauer ein bisschen
systematischer eben wissenschaftlicher
hinschauen möchte im fall von diesen
beiden war es so dass in kurzer zeit
strauß mutter und glazers vater
gestorben waren
ja so dass sie sich für dieses thema tod
und sterben interessiert haben
vor allen dingen in kombination mit
einer beobachtung die sie gemacht haben
nämlich dass in den seit den 1950 60er
jahren es zu so etwas kommt wie eine
hospitalisierung des sterbens dass die
menschen also plötzlich in immer
größerer zahl in krankenhäusern sterben
das war seinerzeit ja ein
neues phänomen das hat also ihr
interesse geweckt weshalb sie eine
studie gemeinsam durchgeführt haben die
den titel trägt horst bitte personalerin
care and dine patience und in der es
ihnen ja vielleicht so um drei ebenen
von forschungsfragen gingen also
einerseits gingen sie ihn darum
herauszuarbeiten wie die protagonisten
in den krankenhäusern eigentlich handeln
also vor allen dingen die ärztinnen und
das pflegepersonal ja es ging ihnen um
die interaktionen zwischen den
verschiedenen gruppen insbesondere um
die interaktion mit sterbenden patienten
und mit angehörigen ja und es ging ihm
darum die strategien zu rekonstruieren
die die beteiligten akteure verfolgen
erst die handlungsebene die zweite ebene
die gläser und strauß interessiert hat
war eine strukturelle ebene
sie haben sich nämlich gefragt also
welche strukturellen bedingungen sind es
eigentlich die diese zu beobachtenden
interaktion beeinflussen und die dritte
frage die sie sich gestellt haben ja
also welche folgen haben die
beobachteten interaktions mechanismen ja
also dieser dreiklang von handel handeln
struktur und konsequenz ja das ist etwas
was ich eigentlich so durch die gesamte
grounded theory methodologie zieht und
was wir gleich auch noch mal sehen
werden
aber beginnen wir vorne nämlich damit
wie gläser und strauss das gemacht haben
sie einem feld studien durchgeführt
ja in sechs krankenhäusern der region
ist san francisco über einen zeitraum
von drei jahren und in diesen
krankenhäusern haben sie eben auch
wieder ein ethnographische manier also
einerseits teilnehmende beobachtungen
durchgeführt und zwar auf solchen
krankenhaus stationen in den sterben
besonders häufig vorkommt oder
vielleicht vorkamen ihr zum ersten fall
nämlich auf frühgeborenenstation
krebs stationen und auf
intensivstationen ja und sie haben auf
diesen stationen daneben auch interviews
geführt nämlich mit den sterbenden
selbst mit ihren angehörigen und mit dem
professionellen also den ärzten und den
pflegekräften haben soweit also dass
gegenstands bezogene interesse für
unsere zwecke noch wichtiger ist
allerdings vielleicht dass dieser studie
auch ein mythologisches interesse zu
grunde lag ja auch hier ging es wenn man
so will darum eine lücke zu schließen
denn die sagen wir mal soziologische
situation in dieser zeit usa 1950 der
60er jahre war so dass es eigentlich
zwei lager von soziologinnen und
soziologen gab ja also einerseits
nämlich diejenigen denen es darum ging
theorie zu entwickeln sozial und
gesellschaftstheorie zu entwickeln und
diese theorie dann detektiv herr
anzuwenden auf beobachtbare empirische
phänomen das eine lager ja und das
andere lager
das waren empirisch forschende also zum
beispiel die forscherinnen und forscher
der chicago school denen es aber eben
wenig darum ging aus ihren
forschungsergebnissen heraus
theoretische modelle zu abstrahieren und
genau das wollten glazer und strauß
miteinander verbinden und hat deswegen
für eine empirisch begründete theorie
bildung plädiert
ja sie selbst schreiben beschreiben das
mit folgenden worten die übrigens aus
dem buch wird discovery stamm ja sie
haben nicht nur eine inhaltliche
publikation der studie veröffentlicht ja
diese werners dieses werners auf dein
buch sondern sie haben auch eine
methodische publikationen veröffentlicht
pavlov grand prix hat bis heute finden
sich einen großen stellenwert ja und
wird gelegentlich auch so als als
manifest ja der qualitativen
sozialforschung beschrieben und dort
schreiben sie dann unser buch ziele
darauf ab die fähigkeiten von
sozialwissenschaftlern zu verbessern
theorie zu generieren die für ihre
forschung relevant ist wir plädieren in
unserem buch dafür theorie auf die
sozialforschung selbst zu gründen sie
aus den daten zu generieren
wir haben diese position mit der
allgemeinen methode komparative analyse
sowie mit verschiedenen auf die
generierung von grounded theory
abgestellten verfahrensweisen verbunden
also ground jury also heben empirisch
begründete theorie ja ein gänzlich neuer
ansatz und deswegen wenn sie mich fragen
auf jeden fall ein meilenstein für die
qualitative sozialforschung
ja ich habe einleitend ja schon gesagt
also es gibt jetzt innerhalb der graue
theorie methodologie oder innerhalb
dieses dieses ziels empirisch begründete
theorie zu entwerfen verschiedene
konkrete methodische vorgehensweisen ja
nämlich das theoretische sampling und
diskutieren die gucken wir uns gleich an
vorher müssen wir allerdings eine frage
noch kurz thematisieren die auch ganz
wesentlich ist glaube ich für die graue
theorie nämlich die frage der
theoretischen sensibilität die auch hier
in diesem in diesem zitat schon so ein
bisschen getriggert wird was ist damit
gemacht
es geht eigentlich um die rolle des vor
wissens dass ich mitbringe wenn ich als
vorschau oder als forscherin ins feld
gehe ja da gab es also ursprünglich so
eine idealtypische idee insbesondere von
gläsernen mich dass man sich bemühen
sollte wenn man empirisch begründete
theoriebildung machen will
dass man eben völlig ohne vorwissen ins
feld gehen solle stelle machen sie mal
janz dumm und fangen an zu forschen ja
damit man eben keine vorgefertigten
scheuklappen auf hat die dann den
forschungs blick irgendwie einengen er
hat es ist natürlich plausibel aber
gleichzeitig weltfremd vermutlich denn
völlig ohne vorwissen ins feld zu gehen
kann ich mir aus der forschungspraxis
überhaupt nicht vorstellen natürlich ist
es ja so dass wir alle wenn wir jetzt im
krankenhaus forschen wollen dann haben
wir schon sozusagen von hause aus ja
also weil wir selber mal in einem
krankenhaus gelegen haben ja oder weil
wir jemanden besucht haben da haben wir
eine gewisse vorstellung von strukturen
von funktionsweisen auch von von den
berufsgruppen innerhalb der organisation
krankenhaus ja dass wir es überhaupt
organisationen nicht nennen ja das hängt
vielleicht damit zusammen dass wir
irgendwann mal soziologie studiert haben
und von daher schon einen sehr
spezifischen blick auf soziale welt
haben et cetera pp ja dass wir können es
also gar nicht schaffen denke ich ohne
vorwissen ins feld zu gehen und sollten
uns deswegen darum bemühen auch die
vorteile dieses vorwissen zu sehen und
die beschreibend strauß hier jetzt
zusammen mit juliette corbin als
theoretische sensibilität und damit
meinen sie die fähigkeit zu erkennen was
in den daten wichtig ist und dem einen
sinn zu geben
theoretische sensibilität hat zwei
quellen einerseits kommt sie daher dass
man sich in der fachliteratur gut
auskennt und auch als professioneller
und persönlicher erfahrung andererseits
wird theoretische sensibilität während
des forschungsprozesses durch die
kontinuierliche auseinandersetzung mit
den daten erworben
ja dh je mehr ich über einen gegenstand
weiß desto sensibler bin ich dafür in
den daten relevante
packte zu erkennen ja das ist die
positive seite des vor wissens die
allerdings nur eben nicht dazu führen
darf das wäre die negative seite dass
ich schon ins feld gehe ja mit einer
allzu hohen erwartungen an ein
bestimmtes ergebnis also mit gewissen
theoretischen scheuklappen die meinen
blick hängen das darf nicht passieren
und wenn man ins feld geht dann geht es
ja zunächst darum fälle auszuwählen
sampling zu betreiben auch später wenn
man die daten hat geht es darum ja also
innerhalb der daten diejenigen
auszuwählen die man vertieft analysieren
will auch das würde zum sampling zehn
ja- und diese sampling verläuft im sinne
der browns ferry oder überhaupt in der
qualitativen sozialforschung doch anders
als man es vielleicht aus quantitativen
studien kennt die quantitativen studien
habe ich ja ein recht linearen auch
recht klaren forschungsprozess was große
vorteile haben kann ja also ich
operationales ihrem eine forschungsfrage
zu einem erhebungs instrument dann
bestimme ich die grundgesamtheit ja ich
ziehe eine repräsentativen
zufallsstichprobe ja ich erhebe daten
nicht für ihre statistische verfahren
durch ja also grob habe ich diesen
linearen forschungsprozess qualitativen
haben wir es jetzt aber zu tun mit etwas
was gläser und strauß theoretisches
sampling nennen ja das ist ein
forschungs prozess in dem sich
datenerhebung datenauswertungen daten
interpretationen immer wieder mit
einander abwechseln
ich will ihnen das mal an einem beispiel
erläutern und kollege und ich haben mal
zum pilgern geforscht sind also auf den
jakobsweg gegangen und haben da
interviews durchgeführt mit pilgerinnen
und pilgern und dann fängt man ja wenn
man so auf dem jakobsweg ist man mit
einem
ersten interview mit dem fall 1 und
nehmen wir an
da hat man eine frau ja interviewt die
uns mehr oder minder explizit erzählt ja
dass sie das sich auf den jakobsweg
gekommen ist weil ihr vater gestorben
ist und sie das sehr belastet hat ja und
dann führt man dieses interview und
unmittelbar danach würde man also
beginnen ja das interview zu
transkribieren und auszuwerten wenn man
würde das also herausarbeiten okay also
offenbar ist der tod des vaters ja einer
der gründe warum diese frau gepilgert
ist ja und man fängt dann an ja also
theoretische überlegungen anzustrengen
also zu abstrahieren und kommt
vielleicht in diesem interpretations
prozess auf die idee okay also
vielleicht sind es ja lebenskrisen ja
die die menschen zum pilgern bringen und
dann würde man auf basis dieser
überlegung den nächsten fall auswählen
und zwar zunächst einen ähnlichen aber
doch anderen fall man würde einen
minimalen vergleich anstrengen damit man
das in der qualitativen sozialforschung
nennt ja also jetzt würde man zum
beispiel jemanden suchen wo nicht der
vater gestorben ist aber vielleicht
jemanden der kürzlich von seiner frau
verlassen wurde und deswegen in einer
lebenskrise geraten ist ja auch diesen
fall würde man erheben auswerten und
dann abstrahieren in dem sinne dass man
nun versucht diesen pilger typus
lebenskrise zu abstrahieren ja vom vom
konkreten fall tod des vaters hin ja zu
den allgemeinen merkmale einer
lebenskrise die eine bürgerschaft zu
initiieren
ja das würde man so lange tun bis man
für sich diesen ersten typus krisen
pilger festgezurrt hat und dann würde
man auch auf basis dieses beginnt einen
theoretischen modells den nächsten fall
auswählen und zwar jetzt einen völlig
anderen fall ja man würde ich jetzt vom
minimalen in den maximalen vergleich
wechseln und versuchen einen pilger zu
interviewen denn nun so gar keine
lebenskrise hat ja also beispielsweise
ein schüler der nach seinem abitur
pilgert aber diese daten auswertet und
interpretiert dann kommt man vielleicht
so auf die idee okay vielleicht gehen
die leute auch in so biografischen
übergangsphasen pilger neben nach der
schule vor dem studio ja und dann würde
man auf dieser basis wiederum einen
minimalen vergleich machen und zu
versuchen und versuchen einen anderen
pilger zu interviewen der auch an so
einem biografischen übergang steht aber
jetzt vielleicht nicht von der schule
ins studium sondern vielleicht am ende
seines berufslebens herr beim übergang
in die rente und würde dann versuchen
dieses diesen typus ja übergangs pilger
könnte man ihn vielleicht nennen
festzuzurren
und so weiter und so weiter bis man an
einen punkt kommt in gläser und strauss
in der grande theorie als theoretische
sättigung beschreiben also den punkt an
dem man als forschender merkt durch neue
daten kann ich keine grundsätzlich neuen
erkenntnisse mehr gewinn sondern ich
höre in neun fällen eigentlich immer nur
neue spielarten der typen in unserem
fall jetzt der pilger typen die ich
bereits auf basis der analysierten fälle
entwickelt habe halt es beschreiben sie
als theoretische sättigung und wenn man
an diesem punkt es dann hat man eben
eine empirisch begründete theorie
entwickelt durch theoretische sampling
geben eine graue theorie
und wie man das jetzt konkret macht ja
also wie man konkret daten auswertet
dazu gibt es innerhalb der grounded
theory methodologie einige ansätze ich
denke der zentrale ist das codieren ja
also das man hingeht und jetzt zum
beispiel ein interview transkript hat ja
und dass man dieses interview transkript
satz für satz durchgeht und diese sätze
mit abstrakteren codes vorsieht also
beispielsweise hatte die frau erzählt im
märz ist mein vater gestorben
dann würde man einen code bilden tod des
vaters vor drei monaten dann hat
vielleicht jemand an dass ein anderer
pilger erzählt ja im dezember ist meine
schwester gestorben
könnte ein code sein tod der schwester
vor sechs monaten ja und dann würde man
hingehen und versuchen diese codes immer
weiter zu abstrahieren hinzu kategorie
die dann vielleicht gibt am ende lauten
ja tod eines nahen angehörigen innerhalb
der letzten zwölf monate
es könnte eine kategorie sein ja der
mann detailinformationen aufgegeben hat
nämlich das ist im einen fall der vater
im anderen die schwester war das ist
einmal vor drei monaten einmal vor sechs
monaten war und dafür nun aber eine
abstraktere analyse kategorie gewonnen
hat durch diesen ersten schritt des so
genannten offenen codieren in einem
zweiten schritt würde es dann darum
gehen diese so gewonnenen kategorien
miteinander in verbindung zu setzen
das nennt man in der grounded theory
axial diskutieren
zwar deshalb weil das anhand einer achse
verlor ist ja in deren mitte man nun ein
bestimmtes phänomen setzt und dann
versucht die anderen kategorien
da drum rum zu gruppieren und zwar
einerseits die ursächlichen bedingungen
für dieses phänomen die
handlungsstrategien die die akteure
gewählt haben um mit diesem phänomen
umzugehen und die konsequenzen
die daraus gefolgt sind und das würde
man in verbindung mit bestimmten kontext
bedingungen in der in denen das alles
stattgefunden hat ja und da sind wieder
diese drei analyse ebenen die ganz
zentral sind für dich morgen die theorie
nämlich das handeln
die konsequenzen und die strukturen das
klingt vielleicht noch ein bisschen
abstrakt ich zeige ihnen gleich ein
beispiel für so ein jack o dia paradigma
nennt man das also dieses schema hier
aus der eu - auf dahin studie
zuvor müssen wir allerdings auf zwei
ergebnisse schauen der studie
das eine ist eine interessante
beobachtung ja nämlich dass gläser und
strauss in ihrer studie beobachten dass
das krankenhauspersonal latent ja den
sozialen verlust bewertet den der tod
eines patienten einer patientin
mutmaßlich mit sich bringt ja es wird
also latent überlegt welche auswirkungen
wird das auf das soziale umfeld haben
wenn der oder die bald verstört ja und
sie beobachten dass das handeln ja also
dass der umgang des krankenhauspersonals
mit den patientinnen und patienten davon
abhängig gemacht wird wie hoch dieser
sozialer verlust kalkuliert wird
ja also sie beobachten beispielsweise
das sogenannte vip patienten auf
intensivstationen eine andere behandlung
erfahren oder sie beobachten dass
farbige in notaufnahmen schlechter
behandelt werden als meister und das
meinen sie mit kalkulation des sozialen
verlustes und sie entwickeln erneut eine
typologie
diesmal eine typologie von den
sogenannten bewusst heitz kontexten
sterben da ja sie beobachten nämlich
einerseits gibt es das was sie
geschlossenen bewusst heitz kontext
nennen also in diesem fall sind die
patienten ahnungslos wissen nicht von
ihrem bevorstehenden tod
es gibt den argwöhnischen bewusst heitz
kontext wir haben die patienten den
verdacht dass sie bald sterben werden
sind sich aber nicht sicher
es gibt dem bewusst heitz kontext der
wechselseitigen täuschung also hier
wissen eigentlich alle bescheid die
patienten wissen dass wir sterben werden
das pflegepersonal sei es dass die
patienten sterben werden aber sie
sprechen nicht miteinander drüber und
die vierte logische auch möglichkeit
dieser matrix ist tanja deppe der
offenen bewusst heitz kontext ja in dem
alle über den bevorstehenden tod
bescheid wissen und offen miteinander
darüber sprechen und offen damit umgehen
und diese bewusst heitz kontexte ja die
stellen gläser und strauß jetzt auch in
form von codia paradigma da also wenn
wir zum beispiel mal diesen
geschlossenen bewusst heitz kontext
nehmen indem die patientinnen und
patienten nichts haben von ihrem
bevorstehenden tod dann identifizieren
die ursachen dafür nämlich dass die
patientin selbst ihren medizinischen
zustand ja nicht einschätzen können und
dass das personal und auch die
angehörigen die patienten eben nicht
aufklären
ja sie sehen da klare
handlungsstrategien etwas was sie als
verschwiegenheit spiel ja von
krankenhauspersonal und von angehörigen
bezeichnen also dass gespräche
abgebrochen werden dass man es vermeidet
über die zukunft zu sprechen et cetera
pp
das bleibt nicht ohne folgen als
konsequenzen des geschlossenen bewusst
heitz kontext identifizieren sie dass
die patienten sich eben nicht auf dem
tod vorbereiten können ja und dass die
situation durchaus auch für personal und
angehörige belastend ist ja dass hier
also dieses verschwiegenheit spiel und
hoher energie um psychische belastung
spielen müssen und die strukturellen
bedingungen
diese geschlossenen bewusstseins kontext
ist dann unter anderem dass zum beispiel
die krankenakten getrennt von den
patienten aufbewahrt werden so dass die
sie nicht einsehen können
ja und dass die gespräche des personals
hinter verschlossenen türen statt
ja das wäre also ein beispiel für eine
anwendung des kurier paradigmas in der
studie
werners of 3 und wenn wir auf
gütekriterien schauen dann ist es so
dass diese studie natürlich par
excellence ja sozusagen also von ihrer
methodologischen idee her per se das
gute kriterium der empirischen
verankerung erfüllt also das ist uns
natürlich immer wichtig sein muss im
forschungsprozess darauf zu achten dass
die abstraktionen ja dass die
interpretationen die wir vornehmen
auch tatsächlich begründet bleiben in
konkreten empirischen daten also dass
man mit so einem theoretischen modell
wie ines steinecke das mal formuliert
hat dicht an den daten bleibt zum
beispiel indem man kodifizierten
methoden anwendet dazu so wie ich sie
ihnen hier vorstelle ja also
beschriebene etablierte methoden der
qualitativen sozialforschung empirische
verankerung kann man erreichen indem man
hinreichend der text belege einfügt ja
immer wieder zitate aus der interviews
oder passagen aus den
beobachtungsprogramm gegen den
forschungsbericht ein arbeitet in dem
man wirklich durchexerziert also wie man
abstraktionen vornimmt anhand eines
falles anhand eines konkreten beispiels
und gerade in neuerer zeit häufig
praktiziert in qualitative
sozialforschung ist die kommunikative
validierung also dass man mit seinen
untersuchungsergebnissen im anschluss
noch einmal
zurück geht zu den beforscht zu seinen
interviewpartnerinnen und
interviewpartner und die ergebnisse mit
ihnen bespricht und um einschätzung
bittet diese vier punkte können
empirische verankerung sichten sichern
und ein weiteres kriterium ist dass der
limitation ja also die frage kann ich
die ergebnisse einer konkreten studie
vor allgemeiner naja also strauß zum
beispiel und gläser die haben wir jetzt
in amerikanischen krankenhäusern
geforscht und eben diese kalkulation des
sozialen verlustes herausgearbeitet und
die typologie der bewusstheit kontexte
und jetzt ja die frage gut kann man das
auch übertragen beispielsweise auf
deutsch krankenhäuser ja so kann ich
dieses theoretische modell dieser
typologie generalisieren über die
untersuchten fälle hinaus
und dieser frage kann ich mich nähern
indem ich ganz explizit fall
kontrastierung durchführe
ja und nach abweichungen suche innerhalb
meiner daten also gläser und strauß
beispielsweise haben dann auch
begleitstudien durchgeführt in
krankenhäusern anderer kulturkreise ja
um einen möglichst großen kontrast
erheben zu können und sie haben sich
dann eher mythologisch als konkret mit
der frage beschäftigt ja ob man aus
ihrem modell eine allgemeinere theorie
entwickeln kann also das tun sie
wohlgemerkt nicht inhaltlich bewegen
aber sie diskutieren die frage ob man es
könnte ende discovery of graue theorie
und zwar am beispiel des sozialen
verlustes was ich ihnen eben gesagt habe
denn für sie sehe wenn es denn möglich
wäre der weg von der gegenstands
bezogenen brown the tree zur allgemeinen
sozial theorie so aus oder er könnte so
aussehen dass man diese kalkulation des
sozialen verlustes von sterbenden
abstrahieren und generalisieren könnte
zu einer theorie des sozialen wertes von
menschen ja also dann würde es nicht
mehr um den sozialen verlust sterbender
sondern generell um den sozialen wert
aller menschen gehen und es würde nicht
nur gehen oben die behandlung der
patienten im krankenhaus sondern es
würde generell gehen um den umgang ja
vielleicht auch den innerhalb des
dienstleistungsbereichs ja um den umgang
mit menschen auf basis des latent
kalkulierten sozialen werte also so
könnte ein weg ausgehen wenn man diese
frage wohl wollen positiv beantwortet
und sagt ja ich kann meine
untersuchungsergebnisse generalisieren
dann könnte man so von der gegenstands
bezogenen graue theorie zur allgemein
sozial theorie com
und einen dritten meilenstein möchte ich
jedem vorstellen nämlich die qualitative
inhaltsanalyse und da fällt einem
natürlich als erstes dieser mann ein
philipp meiring hat ein sehr bekanntes
lehrbuch geschrieben dass mittlerweile
auch glaube in der zwölften auflage
vorliegt er ist in münchen geboren jahr
hat hat pädagogik psychologie und
soziologie dort studiert und dann in
ludwigsburg und klagenfurt geforscht und
gelehrt eines der ersten
forschungsprojekt hat den mann beteiligt
war
das war eine studie namens kognitive
kontrolle in krisensituationen jan dfg
projekt ende der 70er anfang der 80er
jahre geleitet von dieter und karl
hauser ja und in diesem
forschungsprojekt war meiringen als
doktorand tätig und in dem projekt ging
es um arbeitslose lehrerinnen und lehrer
ja also bekommen sozusagen zurück zum
thema arbeitslosigkeit und es gibt in
dieser studie auch ganz explizite bezüge
zu marienthal aber gleichwohl haben wir
es natürlich mit einer völlig anderen
situation zu tun also wir haben es in
den 1980 er jahren in deutschland
natürlich mit einem ganz anderen
lebensstandard zu tun als in den 30er
jahren in österreich ja vor allem auch
mit einer ganz anderen
wohlfahrtsstaatlichen absicherungen ja
also diese diese existenzielle armut
dass die menschen ihre katzen und hunde
gegessen haben wie in marienthal
die hatten wir natürlich gott sei dank
ja in den 1980 er jahren in deutschland
nicht mehr und weiterer unterschied
obwohl es in beiden fällen um das
gleiche forschungsthema geht es dass es
jetzt hier in dieser studie psychologie
der krisenbewältigung ja um die
individuelle bewältigung von
arbeitslosigkeit geht während es in
marienthal ja eher um dieses soziogramm
ging ja also die soziale gruppe und ihre
betroffenheit von arbeitslosigkeit im
mittelpunkt stand und vielleicht weitere
unterschied das muss man fairerweise
auch sagen also diese studie psychologie
der krisenbewältigung hat natürlich ein
ganz anderes sehr dezidierte
theoretisches fundamenten vor allen
dingen sozial psychologisches fundament
während die arbeitslosen von marienthal
ja auf einer viel empirischen ebene
unterwegs war
das ziel der studie das beschreiben die
autoren folgendermaßen ja es ging um
eine differenzierte beschreibung der
individuellen konfrontation mit der
situation arbeitslosigkeit
arbeitslosigkeit wird dabei als
potenzielle krisensituation aufgefasst
die auf bestimmte strukturelle
bedingungen und inhaltliche faktoren
zurück geht die zu emotionalen
reaktionen zum beispiel zu einer
veränderung der identität führt und
zugleich bestimmte bewältigung versuche
erfordert aus diesem übergeordneten ziel
haben sie konkrete forschungsfragen
abgeleitet es ging darum
herauszuarbeiten wie erleben menschen
die krisensituation in ihrem alltag wie
entstehen die krise überhaupt wie gehen
die menschen damit um
und was folgt daraus für die weitere
persönlichkeitsentwicklung
auch hier also verschiedene eben leben
struktur handeln konsequenzen mit einem
spezifischen fokus auf
sozialpsychologische forschungsfragen
was sie methodisch gemacht haben in der
studie sind interviews eine ganze menge
nämlich insgesamt 600 heute würde man
sagen experten interviews mit
lehrerinnen und lehrern ja mit zwei
besonderheiten
erstmals haben wir es zu tun mit einer
längsschnitt untersuchung
das ist etwas sehr außergewöhnliches ja
also eine qualitative längsschnittstudie
findet sich
eher selten dass im quantitativen
bereich viel häufiger qualitativen haben
wir es ja meist eher mit momentaufnahmen
zu tun sowie wird es bei den anderen
beiden studien sich vorgestellt hatte
auch der fall war
hier ist es eine längsschnittstudie an
der insgesamt 104 lehrerinnen und lehrer
beteiligt waren ja und die wollten über
den zeitraum von einem jahr bis zu
sieben mal interviewt so dass man eben
auf diese 600 interviews kommt die erste
besonderheit die zweite besonderheit ist
dass man gruppen gebildet hat ja man hat
zwei untersuchungsgruppen gebildet
nämlich einerseits lehrerin die
unmittelbar nach ihrer ausbildung also
nach dem staatsexamen arbeitslos malen
und andererseits lehrerinnen und lehrer
die nach ihrer ausbildung zunächst nur
eine befristete anstellung gefunden
haben ja was seinerzeit ja eine sehr
besondere situation war weil es in den
1970 er und 1980 er jahren dieses dieses
unbefristete normalarbeitsverhältnis in
vollzeit natürlich noch viel weiter
verbreitet war als heute wo befristete
verträge ja in vielen branchen ja eher
der regelfall als die ausnahme sind ja
und man hat drittens schließlich eine
kontrollgruppe
in die studie miteinbezogen ja also man
hat 25 lehrerinnen und lehrer interviewt
die jetzt eben nicht von
arbeitslosigkeit betroffen waren sondern
direkt nach ihrer ausbildung auf
unbefristete planstellen ihren dienst
antreten konnten
das ist auch sehr selten für qualitative
studien ja man kennt es ja auch aus
naturwissenschaftlicher forschung gut ja
auch gerade in diesen zeiten wenn man
viele von impfstudien hört et cetera pp
weiß man ja wie wichtig dass hier im
naturwissenschaftlichen bereich ist dass
ich kontrollgruppen habe also dass ich
den studien jetzt einer gruppe den
tatsächlichen impfstoff und der anderen
gruppe ein placebo gebe etc pp der
sozialforschung dass er sehr helfen
gerade einen qualitativen bereich hier
hat man es aber so gemacht und diese
interviews die wurden mit hilfe von
leitfäden geführt auch das macht man ja
häufig ja also dass man sich zumindest
vor den interviews stichpunkte macht
über welche themen man sprechen möchte
im interview also so würdig einen
leitfaden verstehen nicht so sehr dass
da ganz konkret die frage formulierung
vorgegeben sein sollte auch nicht so
sehr dass die reihenfolge der fragen
ganz strikt vorgegeben seien beute das
führt doch zu sehr unnatürliche
gesprächssituationen aber es ist
natürlich gut als interviewerin oder
interview ja also stichworte an der hand
zu haben über welche themen ansprechen
will
wenn man sich die studie mal anschaut
die magd er jetzt gar nicht so im detail
darauf eingehen es ist ein interessanter
leitfaden also weil er auch theoretische
aspekte beinhaltet also das was in
runden klammern steht in der ersten
frage die es hier beispielhaft
formuliert mit was empfinden sie jetzt
angesichts ihrer arbeitslosigkeit eher
hoffnung oder eher aussichtslosigkeit
und steht den klammern hin immer
dahinter das ist nun um die emotionale
komponente geht und in den spitzen
klammern stehen mögliche nachfragen ja
also nämlich in abhängigkeit von der
antwort wird dann gefragt wie viel
hoffnung oder wieviel aussichtslosigkeit
vorliegt und etwas war es auch sehr
interessant ist was ich nur selten
bislang gesehen habe sind diese linien
die sie im unteren teil dieses ganz
kleinen auszug aus dem interview
leitfaden sehen
dort kann der die interviewerin
nämlich vor dem interview bestimmte
informationen über den interview ii
eintragen er dass dieser
längsschnittstudie geschuldet also dass
man sich vor dem interview notizen
gemacht hat was denn in den vergangenen
interviews schon gesagt wurde und dass
man da nun noch einmal nachfragen kann
mittels dieses instruments wurden also
die 600 interviews geführt was zu einer
menge daten geführt hat nämlich zu
insgesamt 20.000 seiten transkript das
eine ordentliche menge braucht große
studie mit diesen 600 interviews auch
den kleineren studien unserer pilger
studie zum beispiel
es ist aber so dass wir am ende mehrere
tausend transkript seiten hatten und das
ist natürlich auch ein problem
qualitativer forschung ja dass man nun
also wege finden muss wie man mit diesem
sehr umfangreichen datenmaterial
eigentlich umgeht
und ich denke das ist eine der
besonderheiten der qualitativen
inhaltsanalyse dass sie hier ganz
explizit also möglichkeiten an die hand
gibt wie man material komprimieren kann
und wie man redundanzen innerhalb des
materials reduzieren kann
das ist denke ich ihre erste
besonderheit dass wenn wir das mal an
einem beispiel anschauen ist es zum
beispiel so dass in den interviews nach
einem praxisschock gefragt wurde also ob
man nach der ausbildung wenn man dann
das erste mal vor einer schulklasse
stand und unterrichtet hat ob man da so
etwas erlebt hat wie einen praxisschock
ja und da sagt jetzt einer der
interviewten lehrer praxisschock ich
habe es in der arbeit die ich da
geschrieben habe auch verwendet muss ich
sagen habe ich eigentlich nicht direkt
gehabt sagt er
und ganz ähnlich wie wird das eben bei
dem kodierenden der graue theorie
besprochen hat haben würde man jetzt
hingehen und die transkripte satz für
satz durchschauen und im fall der
inhaltsanalyse würde man aus diesem satz
zunächst eine paraphrase bilden die
sehen sie in dieser großen tabelle ganz
links oben mir also aus dem gerade
zitierten interview satz wurde in dieser
studie die paraphrase gebildet
praxisschock selbst nicht direkt gehabt
also wir nennen es nicht ja kodieren
sondern wir nennen es paraphrasieren das
übersetzen des interviews zitat in eine
zunächst neutralere abstraktere sprache
so dass sich am ende eine liste sie
sehen hier nur einen winzig kleinen
auszug aus dieser studie am ende eine
liste von paraphrasen findet ja und
diese paraphrasen das ist ein ganz
entscheidender schritt bei der material
reduktion die werden daraufhin
generalisierter aus der paraphrase
praxisschock selbst nicht direkt gehabt
wurde also die generalisierung gebildet
keinen praxisschock so dass man in der
mittleren spalte dann eine reihe von
generalisierungen hat und dann tut man
zwei dinge erstens streicht man
redundante generalisierung ja also sie
sehen zum beispiel dass kein
praxisschock sowohl in zeile 1 vorkommt
als auch in zeile 7 und ins heiles
lieben wurde diese generalisierung
gestrichen weil sie redundantes ja und
das zweite was ich nun tue ist ich gehe
hin und ich verbinde zusammenhängende
generalisierungen so wie ich bei der
grounded theory eben verschiedene
kategorien abstrahiert ja so aus der
zusammenschau
mehrere paraphrasen daraufhin mehrere
generalisierung folgt in der rechten
spalte nun eine generalisierte
paraphrase die da lautet kein
praxisschock wegen flexibilität
realismus anpassungsfähigkeit und reden
mit kollegen also hier das ist schon so
kleines theoretisches modellen ist ein
kausalzusammenhang weil man nun sagt
welche bedingungen müssen eigentlich
erfüllt sein damit jemand so einen
praxisschock nach seiner ausbildung eben
nicht erlebt ähnlich wurde das in dieser
zweiten generalisierten paraphrase
gemacht eine rakete strom
ob man auch ohne disziplinarmaßnahmen
gegenüber den schülerinnen und schüler
unterrichten kann
das ist der erste schritt der material
reduktion
das kommt dann ein zweiter schritt indem
man sozusagen nun wieder vorne anfängt
ja und diese generalisierte paraphrase
keinen praxisschock wegen flexibilität
realismus anpassungsfähigkeit und reden
mit kollegen her nimmt und noch einmal
generalisiert also auf ein vorher
definiertes abstraktion niveau bringt
das verknappt ja so dass die
generalisierung nun lautet kein
praxisschock wenn flexibel und
anpassungsfähig reden mit kollegen
auch hier würde man dann in der
mittleren spalte hingehen und diese
generalisierung des zweiten schrittes
durch schauen schauen welches sind
redundant diese würde man streichen und
sie nur an einer stelle übernehmen so
dass sich am ende eine induktiv
gebildete kategorie habe die sich aus
ganz vielen ursprünglichen interview
zitaten die dann traf rasiert wurden
generalisiert wurden ja die zu
synthetisieren wurden dann noch mal
gerne realisiert worden am ende habe ich
eine sehr komprimierte induktiv
gebildete kategorie die im fall der
dieser studie lautet praxisschock kann
selbstvertrauen stark mindern und
belasten wenn
keine übung da ist das destruktive
kritik und anpassungs zwangen an seminar
lehrer nicht weggesteckt wird und man
nicht völlig von sich überzeugt ist sie
merken da stecken jetzt schon eine menge
anderer aspekte mit drin
die sich aus anderen paraphrasen und
generalisierung dieser im original
natürlich sehr langen tabelle
zusammensetzen das kann ich hier kaum
darstellen
in der zeit die uns zur verfügung steht
aber empfehle ihn sehr also auch
durchaus mal reinzuschauen eben diese
studien psychologie der
krisenbewältigung bei leben solche
methodischen aspekte ja oder wie man
eigentlich von den daten zu einem
ergebnis gekommen ist sehr
nachvollziehbar und sehr transparent
dokumentiert wird insbesondere von
philipp maier haben also diese material
reduktion ja also die halte ich doch für
etwas sehr wesentliches der
inhaltsanalyse für etwas wichtiges auch
also weil irgendeine form der material
konzentration in qualitative forschung
eigentlich immer wichtig erst um daten
handhabbar zu machen für die auswertung
für die interpretation auf ein anderes
merkmal der inhaltsanalyse möchte ich
jetzt fast schon abschließend eingehen
und das ist die strukturierung des
materials ist ja also wir haben ja
gerade davon gesprochen dass die
kategorie induktiv entwickelt wurden ist
aus den daten heraus fast schon graue
theorie dass es eigene spielart der
inhaltsanalyse es gibt aber auch die
strukturierende qualitative
inhaltsanalyse die einen anderen weg
geht
die nämlich dass kategoriensystem also
na also die zusammenschau aller
kategorien nicht induktiv entwickelt
sondern ex ante also sozusagen detektiv
auf der basis des bereits vor
vorliegenden forschungsstand hat da gibt
es klare ablauf schieben ja also ich
beschäftige mich erst mal mit der frage
was ist eigentlich meine analyse einheit
im transkript einerseits wird
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu
feingliedrig seien eine ganze antwort
eines interviewpartners ein bisschen zu
grob also irgendwo dazwischen bewegen
sich analyse einheiten dann geht man hin
und entwickelt ein kategoriensystem und
schaut also den forschungsstand durch
yaman lässt sein vorwissen mit
einfließen und extrahiert dann ist ein
wichtiger begriff der inhaltsanalyse aus
den daten extrahiert man dann diejenigen
fundstellen also meinetwegen die
interviewer zitate die zur beantwortung
der forschungsfrage entscheidend sind
und eben nur diese relevanten fundstelle
und würde sie dann kategorisiert
paraphrasiert sieht man generalisiert
sie und diese generalisierung die
kategorisiert man dann in ja ein
kategoriensystem das allerdings initial
nicht auf den daten beruht sondern auf
theoretischen vor überlegung beruht
wichtig ist ja und das ist denke ich
kann selbstverständlicher schritt in der
zeitgenössischen inhaltsanalyse dass man
der während dieses prozesses immer
wieder seien ja theoretisch entwickeltes
kategoriensystem überprüft dass man es
modifiziert dass man kategorien nochmal
ausdifferenziert dass man merkte ich
muss neue kategorien entwickeln weil ich
gar nicht meine ganze generalisierung
sonst irgendwo sinnvoll zuordnen kann ja
also es ist eigentlich ein zusammenspiel
von detektiven und induktiver kategorie
bildung da sagen wir von detektive
kategorie bildung & induktiver kategorie
modifikation das ist natürlich große
vorteile bringt insofern wenn ich die
kategorien auf basis von vorwissen und
forschungsstand entwickler ja dass sich
dann viel unmittelbarer
anschließen kann an bereits vorhandenen
forschungsstand ja das ist denke ich
etwas was die inhaltsanalyse in
besonderer weise leisten kann und ein
beispiel nur kurz herausgegriffen aus
der studie
das wäre zum beispiel die kategorie
selbstvertrauen ja also die hatte man in
dieser studie eben im vorfeld entwickelt
ich sagte ja schon man hat so ein
sozialpsychologischen theorie rahmen in
dieser studie
ja man hat sozusagen die theoretisch
begründete vermutung schon ex ante
gehabt dass jetzt das handeln vor dem
hintergrund von arbeitslosigkeit oder
das auch das erleben und das bewältigen
von arbeitslosigkeit vielleicht etwas zu
tun haben könnte mit selbstvertrauen
also das war eine theoretische vor
überlegung noch bevor man die interviews
geführt hat darum hat man die kategorie
selbstvertrauen mit in das kategorie
system aufgenommen
man hat dann auch auf basis des
forschungsstandes ja aufgenommen das
selbstvertrauen verschiedene
ausprägungen haben kann es kann hoch
sein es kann niedrig seinem original
gibt es auch noch eine kategorie
mittlere selbstvertrauen und wichtig ist
nun in so einem kategoriensystem dass
man diese einzelnen kategorien und ihrer
ausprägung möglichst exakt definiert
also man muss sagen wann fällt eine
generalisierte paraphrase in diese
kategorie das ist insbesondere dann
wichtig wenn man große projekte
durchführt und mehrere forschende
gleichzeitig kategorisiert ja dann
brauchen sie diese regeln
da fügt man dann auch gerne anker
beispiele ein also prototypische
interview zitate ja die man einer
kategorie zugeordnet hätte und man
benennt gerade wenn man es mit mehrere
macht die regeln also in dem fall zum
beispiel dass mehrere oder das alle
aspekte der definition gegeben sein
müssen damit eine generalisierte
paraphrase dieser kategorie zugeordnet
werden kann
das wäre also ein beispiel für eine
detektive kategorisierung in ein ex ante
entwickeltes kategorie system im rahmen
einer qualitativen inhaltsanalyse das
nicht ganz folgenlos komme ich gleich
noch mal drauf zurück zuvor ein blick
auf die ergebnisse des geschieht sehr
systematisch auch in dieser studie die
ergebnisse aufbereitung und da wird also
einen variablen schema entwickelt indem
man sagt die belastung ja die ein lehrer
oder generalisiert dann vielleicht die
ein mensch durch arbeitslosigkeit
empfindet die ist von verschiedenen
aspekten abhängig dass spielen
gesellschaftliche faktoren mit ein also
die objektiven voraussetzungen die
eigene lebenssituation aber unter
kognitiven mediatoren eben auch unsere
kategorie selbstvertrauen auch die nimmt
also offenbar einen einfluss darauf wie
belasten durch arbeitslosigkeit empfinde
und sogar einen nicht unwichtigen also
schreiben sondern die autorinnen und
autoren dieser studie ja und stellen das
auch in form eines diagramms da ein
bisschen ungewöhnlich für qualitative
forschung also weil sie zeigen können
dass die empfundene belastung durch
arbeitslosigkeit im zeitverlauf zwischen
t1 erstes interview und t7 letztes
interview dass die belastung durch
arbeitslosigkeit bei menschen mit
niedrigem selbstvertrauen im zeitverlauf
zunimmt während sie bei menschen mit
hohem selbstvertrauen
sogar ein bisschen abnimmt
im zeitverlauf das ist also so 1 der
auch natürlich sehr vielfältigen
ergebnisse dieser studie psychologie der
krisenbewältigung
ich denke was gütekriterien angeht kann
man einerseits ja also gut sehen
anhand dieser studie wie man eine studie
transparent gestalten kann also all
diese beispiele auf die ich ihnen jetzt
gerade hier kurz auf den folien gezeigt
habe die stammen eben aus im kontext der
studie entstandenen publikationen also
das ist sehr stark dokumentiert und das
ist eben wichtig dass leserinnen und
leser nachvollziehen können ja wie
bestimmte untersuchungsergebnisse
zustande gekommen sind
es geht nicht darum
untersuchungsergebnisse zu überprüfen
oder in irgendeiner weise zu validieren
also das ist etwas was man aus dem
quantitativen bereich kennt aber es geht
doch darum den forschungsprozess
transparent und nachvollziehbar zu
machen nicht zuletzt natürlich für
kolleginnen und kollegen für
gutachterinnen und gutachter ja die
hervor publikationen eine studie oder
vor begutachtung der studie im rahmen
eines qualifikations verfahrens ja sich
einen eindruck vom untersuchungs design
und vom forschungsprozess verschaffen
müssen ja wichtig ist beispielsweise und
all dies geschieht in der studie in
recht vorbildlicher weise ja dass man
das sample erläutert begründet warum man
fälle ausgewählt hat dass man im
methoden teil ja das erhebungs und
auswertungsverfahren erläutert dass man
die daten dokumentieren den anhängen
oder neuerdings gibt es ja auch
repositorien ja in denen man kolleginnen
und kollegen auch qualitative daten für
sozusagen sekundär forschung zur
verfügung stellen kann
das geht natürlich nicht zuletzt auch
darum also immer wieder die
abstraktionen die man vor nimmt die
interpretation die man vor dem zu
bebildern und zb durch interview zitate
zu untermauern dass etwas kritischere
güte kriterium was häufig gegen die
inhaltsanalyse in anschlag gebracht wird
dass es die offenheit
wichtig nämlich ist eben das hatten wir
im zuge der theorie und der
theoretischen sensibilität schon gesagt
ja dass wir nicht durch theoretische
vorfestlegungen unseren forschende blick
eingrenzen und dass wir jederzeit offen
sind für neue und überraschende
ergebnisse im feld
und da ist es natürlich jetzt so könnte
man denken
zunächst mal problematisch wenn eine
strukturierende qualitative
inhaltsanalyse ihr kategoriensystem
detektiv entwickelt und dann alles was
sie an daten paraphrasiert und
generalisiert in dieses zuvor
entwickelte kategoriensystem einordnet
so könnte man denken aber ich hoffe ich
konnte ihnen zeigen anhand dieses
ablaufs schemas der hat es auch die
inhaltsanalyse natürlich möglichkeiten
hat empirisch begründet induktiv ihr
analyse raster jederzeit zu modifizieren
und dass sie dies auch tut das halte ich
für sehr wichtig denn um es mal
abschließend mit jörg strübing zu sagen
ja wichtig für uns qualitative
sozialforscherin und sozialvorsteher ist
wir beugen uns überraschen lassen wollen
unseren gesprächspartnern möglichkeiten
organisieren um im interview gespräch
dinge zu äußern gebe nie vermutet hätten
ja wir wollen die map irischen fällt auf
probleme aufmerksam werden und im detail
verstehen lernen deren existenz wird
zuvor nicht einmal geahnt haben
wir wollen offen ins feld gehen und
damit haben wir jetzt eine ganze liste
von den gütekriterien empirische
sozialforschung die erarbeitet
gegenstands angemessenheit also eine
untersuchungs design an gegenstand
anpassen nicht umgekehrt den eigenen
einfluss jederzeit reflektieren also
reflektierte subjektivität theoretische
modelle müssen dicht an daten seien sie
müssen empirisch verankert sein
wir müssen uns immer wieder mit der
frage der limitation beschäftigen wie
weit darf ich meinen spezifischen
erkenntnisse zu einer allgemeineren
theorie generalisieren
die
unsere forschung muss inter subjektiv
nachvollziehbar und offen sein und es
gibt noch zwei weitere kriterien die
immer wieder diskutiert werden das eine
ist die kohärenz also es darf innerhalb
der eigenen daten natürlich keine
widersprüchlichkeiten geben das hatten
wir schon kurz tangiert im rahmen des
hygiene also es darf eben keine daten
geben die dem modell das sich entwickelt
habe widersprechen ja und es geht
natürlich auch um die frage der relevanz
also der bedeutung unserer erkenntnisse
für den einschlägigen fach diskurs und
damit hoffe ich konnte ich ihnen einen
kleinen einblick geben in drei
klassische studien die ich tatsächlich
für meilensteine der modernen
qualitativen sozialforschung halte also
die jeweils wichtige neue ideen für
einen qualitativen forschungsprozess mit
sich gebracht hat ja bei den
arbeitslosen von marienthal haben wir es
da sicher noch mit den anfängen zu tun
ja aber wir haben da eben diese idee
also nicht nur statistisch zu gucken
auch nicht nur beliebig im sinne eine
reportage zu gucken sondern wir haben da
diese idee mit den mitteln der
sozialforschung ja diese laborsituation
mariental zu durchdringen sich in die
situation einzuführen wie die autorinnen
und autoren das genannt haben und wir
haben ein sehr schönes beispiel für
gegenstands angemessenheit ja so wir
haben dieses sehr originelle sehr
pragmatische sehr kreative untersuchungs
die sein dass man ja auch wirklich das
muss man unterstreichen als
pionierarbeit sehen muss denn all diese
methoden gab es vor der studie ja noch
nicht wirklich von der quantentheorie ja
können wir dieses plädoyer mitnehmen für
eine empirisch begründete theoriebildung
ja also dass all das was wir an
theoretischen modellen entwickeln auch
tatsächlich fuß muss auf empirischen
daten ja und sie geordnet siri hat
ebenso einen ganzen jahr wenn man so
will ein werkzeug
asten mitgebracht mit dem theoretischen
sampling ja mit dem kodieren später dann
auch mit maps ja et cetera pp also eine
ganze reihe von instrumenten mit denen
ich qualitative daten analysieren kann
und die qualitative inhaltsanalyse denke
ich hatte uns ein werkzeug mit gegeben
ja das also umfangreiches datenmaterial
handhabbar und einer analyse zugänglich
macht ja und sie hat uns durch dieses
wechselspiel aus reduktion und induktion
also eine gute möglichkeit mit gegeben
also dass unsere theoretischen modelle
nicht immer neu entwickelt werden müssen
sondern dass sie natürlich von
vorneherein schon durch das
untersuchungs design auch anschlussfähig
gemacht werden können
an den bereits vorhandenen
forschungsstand daher halte ich die
arbeitslosen von marienthal googles auf
dagegen und die psychologie der
krisenbewältigung für meilensteine der
qualitativen sozialforschung und danke
für die aufmerksamkeit
einen schönen tag was sagen